I'm Martin Platt I was the Africa editor
the BBC World Service news uh until I
retired in 2013 and I am now the senior
research fellow at The Institute of
Commonwealth studies
thank you Alan
hi I am Alan Boswell the Horn of Africa
director at the international crisis
we're a global organization uh conflict
prevention and conflict resolution
headquartered in Brussels perfect
Martin's kick us off should we have seen
this coming
yes and no yes in the sense that it was
increasingly clear that you couldn't
have to use an African metaphor two
bulls in the same field uh and you know
the the increasing strength of the uh of
hemeti against the Army and the uh srf
as opposed to the Army meant that they
they were really you know getting to a
point where
they were no longer it was no longer
compatible to have them both in a sense
exercising power and you know the state
is supposed to be the only Arbiter of
Armed Force and it was getting to a
point where it was that was no longer
the case and I think that the Army just
decided that in the end they couldn't
really tolerate someone like amiti
general Douglas uh you know being in in
that kind of position any longer
thank you and Alan
yes I would concur with with Martin's
analysis there obviously uh there have
been escalations part of the challenge
was that we had seen a number of
escalatory uh moves um and escalatory
Cycles um just a month earlier in early
March we had seen a massive escalation
that actually required a um a
de-escalation agreement and for one of
these sides hemeti the paramilitary a
leader to pull his forces out of
Khartoum so I think one of the reasons
this was a bit difficult to predict
although everyone knew that tensions uh
were Rising was because we had seen this
cycle of escalation and de-escalation uh
quite a few times I mean but there was
high level
um mediation that was being done both on
the Sudanese level and on the
international level in the days leading
up to this so people were aware that it
was getting quite tense
um uh but no I mean I think it was hard
to predict that you know fighting would
break out exactly when it did thank you
Chris and so where are we at now do you
want to do just a brief kind of outline
of who's who's in control of what who's
running the infrastructure all of that
kind of stuff Martin do you want to
start and then well uh the committee and
the srf are are seem to be in a more
powerful position I mean I was speaking
to somebody this morning they were
saying that they're all over cartoon but
the problem is that we're concentrating
on this is if it's it's a heart room
issue and of course this is a huge
country and a lot of the fighting is
outside of it in the periphery and uh I
mean you'd have to know literally almost
Village by Village as to who is who is
on top and who is so to speak doing well
in this conflict
um but I mean they do have both of them
have vast quantities of arms and
ammunition and hamiti has been had
you know supplementary supplies flown
into him from Libya and that has
assisted him in in his in his position
and uh you know I don't think it's
possible to tell at this stage who is
going to get the upper hand in in any of
this
why is Libby providing ours well with
hafta it in a sense there's a sort of
they're two camps I mean you you have
hafta who runs Eastern Libya
and he is uh in bed so to speak with the
with the Wagner group the Wagner group
is backing hermeti and the hametti is
then in return flying gold out of uh a
lion gold to be flown out of from the
mines that he controls in Sudan to help
pay for uh Putin's war in Ukraine I mean
to put it really bluntly
and you said to me earlier before we
meet that you this is basically a war
over gold is that right well that is
certainly one of the major issues I mean
there was an absolutely fascinating
little uh snippet that uh Bloomberg put
out earlier this month if I may I'll
just read this one paragraph very brief
it says
about three dozen Russians from 58 hours
swallow large workers were questioned on
accusations of gold smuggling earlier
this year this is a uh a front for um
for the Wagner group
um on accusation of gold smuggling
earlier this year the probe was seen as
a potential setback for moscow's
Ambitions in the resource-rich North
African state it also signaled an
escalation in the simmering power
struggle between Sudan's military and
arrival militia whose leader has forged
close ties with Russia but you don't
have to be a genius to know that the
person who's float forged close to ties
with Russia is hermeti
um
Alan
oh
um to answer your question about the
state of play
um the situation has been remarkably
fluid
um we have seen fighting across the
country
um at Darfur the north the East um
throughout this war but I think one of
the remarkable things compared to what
we thought we'd see if this worst case
scenario broke out is we thought we'd
see something looking more like all-out
Nationwide conflict that has occurred
but what actually we're seeing is that
both of these forces are very focused on
control of cartoon this is essentially a
battle for cartoon
um they are holding their forces from
other parts of the country to Khartoum
um this looks very much like a battle
between two men who both ultimately want
to be the top dog um in Sudan um in
terms of who controls what uh most of
again it's very fluid on most of the
reports suggest staff might have more
control at the moment of strategic
locations
um in cartoon but as Martin alluded to
rsf has essentially swarmed the capital
with 10 of thousands of uh militiamen
and there's been a lot of give and take
art yeah
do you do you agree with Martin's
analysis about Libya and Russia
we have seen the reports um we think uh
we don't think Russia right now or
Wagner is a major actor in the um in the
conflict
um we're watching reports we have uh
some sources of our own that suggest
there might have been some of these
cross-border
um uh shipments that came uh from Libya
um I think thus far we've actually uh uh
been surprised that we haven't seen more
external involvement in what we've seen
so far
um but of course it's impossible to know
if we're seeing uh the full picture just
to say
um for hemeti um you know he's also
being heavily pressured uh from the West
not to accept any uh arms from Wagner as
well so it's it's difficult to say
exactly how that would um how that would
play out
okay Henry
following on for that would you say that
this is essentially a conflict between
two individuals and their almost
personal Ambitions rather than a
conflict of ideologies or or cultures
I think there are many things that you
can say about it but I mean one of them
of course is that it's personal uh
between the two men uh the second is
that it is also the the so to speak the
traditional divide in Sudanese society
which is between people who live along
the Nile and people who live in the
periphery and that has been one uh you
know it goes back many many years uh and
in a sense in that sense
the you can look at someone like Amity
represents the periphery but again only
one section of the periphery because he
is actually from uh you know his family
comes from Chad he's a resurgat and he
is essentially an Arab who was involved
in the Darfur massacres uh and some of
which were straightforwardly racist
quite frankly
um and so you can't just say that he
therefore represents everybody who's in
the periphery but that is the way it is
seen well as uh the Army is led by
people who are traditionalists and so to
speak represent the traditional system
of you know going up through the Army
living from coming from uh the the
center of the country and that that is
one of the one of the major divisions in
in what you're seeing now thank you very
much um Alan If I Could Turn to You um
is your
opinion that this is a coup or is this
the start of a civil war
oh this looks more to us like the start
of a civil war than a coup
um I'll just say that we um we haven't
seen clear evidence yet of exactly how
it started
um and so uh I wouldn't call it a coup
yeah and uh just further Alan if I may
um how uh does this situation
um
potentially cause instability in the in
the wider region so Central African
Republic Ethiopia Libya Somalia South
Sudan
um Libya is is this
um is this likely to cause greater
instability in those neighboring states
uh yes if we don't see this uh stopped
and arrested soon
um it's almost well it's basically
guaranteed that we will see this suck in
a variety of other armed groups um in
Sudan um this will uh and there are many
other armed groups in Sudan who some of
whom are Rebels some of whom are
Community militias some of whom are
aligned to the government but we've seen
remarkable sort of solidarity mostly uh
for the most part um from those other
groups rejecting this war everyone
pretty much all Sudanese who aren't
these parties see this as catastrophic
and mistake if this drags on uh we will
see this uh fragment we will see all
sorts of different sort of struggles
around the peripheries that will affect
Chad that will affect South Sudan we um
this will affect Libya car Ethiopia
um these are all places that cannot
really afford uh more instability
um I also think if this drags on the
risk is quite high that we will see
major external intervention and this
could become a regional war and that you
know as as we all know not only makes
the situation worse but makes it a lot
harder to resolve once it hits that
point so we've been very focused on
seeing how can we get a ceasefire soon
because this once this gets much worse
and much more multi-sided it'll just
become much more difficult to um to to
stop thank you just just finally um if
I'm a team Martin
um following on for what you were saying
earlier on in terms of the the different
uh bases uh does the rsf have a original
base
um that could sustain it if this were to
become a longer term Civil War I mean
they did grow out of the junju wheat you
know they they did grow out of Darfur
that is where hermeti grew his his base
and that is where he still gets a lot of
his support from but not only from them
and he gets it from other areas and I
mean I think one I would very much agree
with what was said about the the spread
because I mean if you look at who are
his allies uh I mean one of his his
allies is the Eritrean government
um the president isas has had a finger
in every single pie every one of his
neighbors and he received hametti
earlier this year they are very close uh
and the one thing that links him hemeti
and hafta
is their relationship with the Russians
now I'm not trying to say this is a
Russian plot I think the Russians fish
in shall we say stormy seas if to mix a
messifer
um and this is this is a real storm and
you know the the flights were of
bringing the the uh the weapons in to
Libya and then from Libya into into
Darth or have been you know they've been
tracked they've been shown on satellites
this is not something that you know that
they are available and so it is the
relationship between the uh the region
and the and the region and the internal
players that will call they will really
see how this develops and how it plays
out okay thank you very much just on
that point so obviously you were talking
about how essential the gold coming out
of Sudan is funding uh Putin's illegal
renewed invasion of Ukraine so I presume
hostilities will harm him because it
will interrupt the ability to get gold
out or is that not have we not see any
cessation of that during that last 10
days you know Sudan is such an enormous
country uh you know as long as you
control the gold mines and control the
means of getting them out I don't think
it's going to really stop your the flows
and I mean it's interesting that uh
Bloomberg reckons that
only 20 percent of all gold goes through
official means
that leaves a huge amount to go through
unofficial means and we're talking about
something like four billion dollars so
this is a vast amount of money in in a
tiny and in in a country which has a
tiny budget so this is what these are
the kind of sums of money and if you put
that into then weapons and it it really
does make a huge difference and don't
forget that you know there are already
three countries in Africa which are
almost completely dominated by by the
Wagner group we're talking about Mali
the car and Libya I mean they have a
really stronghold they have a big uh say
in perhaps nine ten perhaps more and
they don't just work at the the physical
level they work at the social level they
have they use all the strengths that the
Russians have in social media and they
they use all of these extremely
effectively I mean they've affect
they've actually forced the French to
leave Mali which is you know an amazing
achievement uh from their point of view
thank you Neil just a quick one share
for me I'm just just given the situation
on the ground both right now and in the
coming days and weeks how crucial is
reliable uh accurate information and the
role of BBC World Service do you think
well as somebody who worked for the BBC
World Service for 30 years I think it's
vital
um and to be honest with you the most
important bit of it would be the the
Arabic Service uh not the not the
English or the I mean you know I worked
in the English service all that time but
you know people do rely on it um and
they know that it is a trustworthy
Source it's something that goes down
Generations it isn't just something that
people pick up uh and you know you can
walk through a market I've walked
through markets in actually South Sudan
not North and heard you know people
listening to them and in fact people
coming up to me and saying oh you're
Martin Platt only because they knew my
voice which is a bit surprising should
we say
but it was fun Alan you touched on the
ceasefire can I ask you what your
assessment is the likelihood of the
cease fire holding obviously although
it's in name holding at the moment
obviously there are reports of jets
flying over and of uh interrupted uh
fire what's your assessment
um these ceasefires to date because of
course they did also agree to a
ceasefire uh for the three days uh
leading up to today uh they have been
patchy
um it is correct that we have uh that
our information is that there has been
um some breaking of the ceasefire
already in the in the Khartoum area um
primarily in omderman
um
um and also possibly in uh in West R4
and in south star four
um generally the uh the the feeling
among diplomats is that it'll be harder
probably to get to the Army
um to fully agree
um uh they have been more resistant to
uh to the talks than the um than the rsf
side has been um but we have to be
realistic about the immediate chances of
ceasefires because they keep breaking
down so I think the important thing is
to just keep pressing towards a
ceasefire and hopefully hope one sticks
I don't believe a ceasefire until it
happens and I mean this one seems to be
very patchy as as I was saying it's I
mean doesn't sound as if it's it's
holding except in particular areas but
you know it's a huge country I mean in
99 of the country there's nothing going
on of course you know the fact it is so
huge I mean I I remember standing on top
of a Jeep looking around in Sudan and
seeing nothing but grass not even one
tree
that's what the country is like it is
absolutely enormous so most of the
country nothing will be happening it is
in very specific areas of the fighting
is happening where there are key uh you
know settlements but uh in most of the
country I presume there's nothing going
on and I mean the real struggle for
people now are particularly trying to
get out of uh Khartoum is you know is
getting fuel getting money and of course
quite a lot of them uh their passports
are in the safes of the embassies
because they would have been looking for
visas or looking for renewals and of
course they can't get them up now
because there aren't any staff left
I was going to ask about Russia but I
think Henry and elysius covered that you
talked about
uh the Wagner group and haftar and Li in
Libya and their support for the rsf but
what about Chinese involvement they're
Sudan's biggest trading partner or
agriculture Health infrastructure
you know they'll have a view but
do they have any influence and is there
any evidence of them having any
involvement I I've seen nothing that
suggested that having involvement and I
mean while the Russians for example
would very much like to have a uh a base
in Port Sudan
um the uh I don't think the Chinese are
interested because they already have one
in Djibouti uh so I don't think there's
that kind of pressure and that was one
of the things that uh
um Omar Bashir you know who was
overthrown by the the current
participants in the conflict uh was in a
sense offering the the Russians was a
base from which they could operate
um and so you know I don't see I haven't
seen anything that suggests any Chinese
involvement at the moment
no evidence of them picking aside at all
not that I'm aware of but I don't know
let's hear it I'd be interested to hear
what Alan said
um we haven't seen any signs in
particular Chinese attempts at mediation
or picking sides um China has supported
the uh ceasefire calls uh at the U.N
security Council as has as has Russia
um uh actually and um the one thing
we've seen interesting from China is the
state media
um or or state aligned media has been
blaming essentially U.S meddling uh for
the for the conflict
uh thank you so much
um Martin you mentioned that Omar
albashir there are reports that he was
broken out of Cobra prison over the
weekend when there appears to be a mass
Escape I'd be their injured in your
assessment as to where he sits within
all of this and what the risks are of
him being out on the loose
I would assume that he would align
himself with the Army but I mean I
really I'm not in the position to make
that that assessment uh I mean I
generally
Alan
yeah we are following those reports with
great interest but I don't have uh we
don't have any uh specific Intel on that
uh just to say if he was if he was freed
and you know sort of popped up again as
a political actor I think it would it
would um
uh it could be a very strange wild card
in the midst of this I do agree I mean I
agree with Martin that if he was to
choose a side on this he would
definitely end up falling more on the on
the Army side but he could just as well
you know be on his own side it would be
very helpful for those of us who haven't
necessarily followed stars because they
would have liked since he was removed
from Power how much of a radicalizing
figure a figure that can bring people
together how much did his being put in
prison reduce his ability to affect
support to maintain support to group and
rally people
is
yeah sure um yeah I mean uh his uh
bashira and his party have been uh uh
ostracized and marginalized and have not
been given really a platform to continue
politicking um there's been quite a lot
of accusations from this sort of uh
civilian political Elite um who were
overthrown in this coup accusing uh
Burnham the Army chief of essentially
rehabilitating the old bashia regime so
there's a lot of there's a lot of uh
suspicion of essentially a
counter-revolution if you will
um
um but I he's not a figure that for
instance is continuing to to have
popular support for himself generally or
people rallying to bring him back into
politics I think if it was free then it
would just it would be something you'd
have to watch
and Martin if you want anything on that
but also how the lack of accountability
around uh Bashir impacts on the scenes
that are unfolding
well I I don't honestly think that
people really assumed there was going to
be much accountability and I mean he's
been put in jail he's but he's been very
uh should we say comfy jail he hasn't he
hasn't really struggled very much in in
that position
um and you know I think he's just sort
of seen as part of the scene rather than
rather than anything else
um I mean the one thing I think that I I
don't know whether it's anything that
you you've thought about I mean you know
the slogan is you know African solutions
to African problems which people come up
with all the time and the real question
is what is the African Union doing about
this and what are the uh the Arab League
doing about it since they you know they
are members of both of those
organizations and you know this is
really extraordinary that the the
African Union has they have they have
mediators they they have appointed
mediators and the mediators as far as I
can see haven't done anything they
haven't arrived in the country they
haven't they haven't managed to get
through at all they may have tried hard
I mean it's Djibouti
in Kenya but they are not on the ground
they're not as far as I can see actually
uh involved in this they may be behind
the scenes but they are not and the
other thing is you may remember that
that Britain along with a lot of other
countries
try to assist the African Union in
getting a standby Brigade going and they
have been Iran since 2010 well where are
they
you know they just are they out there
nowhere on the scene and you know if
anybody was going to intervene in in
this it would really probably have to be
the Egyptians who have a really
substantial Army
um but there's no indication that
anybody in the region is prepared to you
know lift a finger to really in
intervene
I didn't think there's any appetite to
do it they all are prepared to put a bit
of money here there whether it's the
United Arab Emirates the Saudis whoever
but not to actually do the hard lifting
which would would turn African solutions
to African problems from a slogan into a
reality
Chris
just
um can you what you what's your
estimation of the humanitarian situation
at the minute and obviously quite a lot
of ngos have effectively stopped
operating
um how important is it to get them back
in in full operation well it's
catastrophic I mean you know everything
is going down I mean people talk about
lack of medicine there's a lack of water
I mean the hospitals are not working I
think there was something like 50
hospitals in in Khartoum and only five
were operating a couple of days ago
probably it's fewer now they're running
out of everything that they need it's an
atrocious situation
and people are doing what they always do
which is to rely on each other
and to flee and people are already
moving in I think it was 10 20 000
people have moved into Chad joining
other people who had fled into child
before they're moving into South Sudan
and some are moving into Egypt and some
into Ethiopia so people move out of the
out of the country despite it being so
enormous so I think that's the response
but I think the heroic uh efforts really
are with the doctors and the lawyers
groups the civilians who have been you
know who are behind the river the
Revolution and were trying to persuade
the Army uh and the uh the rsf to hand
over power to a civilian Authority and
those groups are still active and still
doing whatever they can in the
circumstances and I think that you know
if there's any any or any uh if there's
anything one can do it would be to
strengthen their hand that's the I think
is the only way towards some kind of
resolution of this crisis but it's going
to be extremely difficult when the men
with the guns really ruled the streets
Alan do you share that view
yes the um the humanitarian uh I this is
the fastest
um uh the fastest growing humanitarian
crisis from a man-made
um circumstances that I've ever seen
you've essentially seen within the
course of a matter of days a collapse of
an entire city of a greater city of some
10 million people and that's just in
cartoon where we have reports from um
the humanitarian situation was not good
uh before this conflict broke out Bashir
was overthrown in 2019 partly because
the economy was so poor and living costs
were so high and it's only gotten worse
since a lot of economic assistance has
been cut off for um uh for for over a
year now as as a pressure tool to get
the military to hand over so yes in
cartoon you essentially have very spotty
electricity temperatures are in their
40s a lot of people are out of drink out
of clean drinking water out of
um food there's been widespread looting
on the rsf fighters have lost a lot of
their logistical Supply chains and
warehouses
um which have been bombed um and are
doing widespread looting uh Christmas
video it's basically it's it's a really
really really terrible situation yeah
Liam
um just to follow that up Alan do you
think that there is a likelihood that
ngos are now going to be forced
basically to constrain or restrict their
support for the work they're doing I'm
conscious that something like three
quarters of the hospitals have already
been knocked out
um do you see ngos basically having to
pull back just to safeguard their own
people
yeah they already are pulling back it's
just uh the uh the security situation
does not allow for a humanitarian
response especially in a context without
any sort of peacekeepers or or third
party
um uh the U.N has talked about forming a
you know a a hub for humanitarian work
in Port Sudan but that's you know in a
different part of the of the country so
this is still very early hours of this
uh of of of what could be a very long
Civil War um if this continues I think
we'll see you know the logistics of a
sort of humanitarian operation
um set up but at the moment it just
hasn't been able to get off the ground
because the security situation in
Khartoum has not allowed it what do you
think the consequences are for the risks
of famine disease
disease outbreaks
um yeah I mean we would hope that we
could just get a ceasefire soon so you
wouldn't descend into um into those sort
of uh scenarios it's difficult to say
what it would look like if we continue
to have an all-out battle for cartoon
um already we're seeing cartoons start
to empty
um of a lot of residents um people who
can afford to are getting on on buses
and trying to to flee basically in in
any direction
um any direction you can so I wouldn't
want to speculate what the long-term
consequences would be in terms of
potentially famine but it's it's um it's
an unusual crisis normally in these wars
you know they take place in rural areas
you have you know people with their
crops destroyed and things like that
this is this is something different this
is a collapse of a city of millions of
people who can't access basic services
or food or water so I think it's just
very unusual and Martin do you think
there are there are things that we could
do to at least support Refugee Flows In
neighboring countries well we can
certainly back the efforts of the unhcr
to try and deal with the influx that's
coming the one other thing I think we
have to remember is that there's there's
been a report today that the World
Health Organization is saying that a
laboratory with them viruses in hartum
has fallen to the rsf and they're using
it to to uh you know as an operational
base and they are extremely worried
about what this could do if if it if it
really becomes a Battleground now I
don't know what's in those in the in
that laboratory and what it might be but
that if the World Health Organization is
saying it's worrying I think we should
be worried too you worried there are
pathogens in that I don't think we lose
I know I have no further information
about I simply we've been told this
polio and other diseases such as that
just to build on that I mean Martin you
spoke about the um the the flow of
refugees to countries like Chad could
you just elaborate in your view uh the
impact it's having on the surrounding
countries uh and on infrastructure in
places like Chad uh or whether there is
sufficient infrastructure to take such a
load on
well there certainly won't be the
infrastructure and people but you know
people will make do I mean I've I've
been on in in Chad when I when they've
been an influx of fighting in Darfur and
you suddenly see you know 50 80 100 000
people coming across the border and uh
onto what is effectively a
um sand year and you know then people
just start uh making do and you know the
the unhcr brings in support very rapidly
they are very used to this and local
people come and help in any way they can
although it does cause tensions with
local people and uh people get by the
other thing that's quite extraordinary
is I mean I remember the I think was the
third day that the camp actually in
existence and uh there were and the
first trucks arrived from across the
Sahara people had heard they were the
people were fleeing there and they
thought there must be some money to make
and they actually brought goods to sell
to the to the to the refugees and they
were there on the base within you know
perhaps it was a week but extraordinary
how fast people respond we tend to look
at the Sahara as being a barrier for
many people it's just a sea to to sail
in and find something to trade in and
that goes back of course hundreds if not
thousands of years so I mean people will
respond very rapidly the other thing one
mustn't forget is that this is a region
that is very used to refugees Sudan
itself
I can't remember how many millions of
refugees but I mean they've had Eritrean
refugees for you know since the 1960s
and they've been very hospitable to them
and have put them up and looked after
them or at least given them a space to
live in not always uh satisfactory but I
mean you know they've given them the
space and I think you know people will
just say well this is what happens in
the region and we'll it's not it's not
that unusual
nephew at Royston final oh sorry will
you bring it out if Alan wanted to but
it's fine
just those with means are traveling to
uh Egypt which is really the only real
um stable country if you will um that
you might want to go to if if you have a
choice um within the region and they're
either going to Egypt or they're going
to Port Sudan and then looking for uh to
leave Sudan out of course Sudan the
refugees who will be fleeing into the
other countries will will be people who
probably have no other choice but to go
to those you know
that Royston flying question
this is not ideological and it's between
two people both who of whom think they
should be in charge
um how fluid is the situation uh anyone
there are people moving from the rsf to
the military or vice versa I haven't
seen any indication of that I mean I
think I think there's a lot of business
as I said you know partly it is because
they they have different constituent
elements I mean one of them is drawn
mainly from the uh the periphery and the
other ones staying drawn mainly from the
the peoples of of the center Center and
the nilotic peoples
so I don't think there's I don't think
there's a swap over I mean there may be
some I mean I'm not saying it's nobody
[Music]
anything Alan
yeah no um it remains uh quite fluid in
terms of Battlefield Dynamics but the
lines are quite these are very different
institutions
um staff has an Air Force and has this
ins you know has a long institutional
history
um but the rsf is essentially a
collection of militias and is run like
basically in a family corporate Empire
um from from one family and is tightly
controlled um so so very very different
uh like Martin said not a lot of
crossover I think where things get fluid
is in terms of potential external
support
um trying to back one of these sides or
if we see one of them essentially be
kicked out of cartoon or lose the Battle
of cartoon and then there's all sorts of
scenarios and um depending on how that
goes
um that's where you could see State
collapse or this really expand into a
much wider uh Civil War
thank you thank you brilliant thank you
both ever so much that was incredibly
informative and helpful answers can I
also thank you for your forbearance with
the uh process of democracy and allowing
us to vote uh we will suspend briefly uh
while we change uh who's giving evidence
to us but thank you both ever so much
the proceeding is currently suspended
district one question uh welcome back to
this session of the Foreign Affairs
committee uh for those just joining us
uh we are fortunately are not able to
contact one of the members of our panel
uh so we are hoping to continue to try
and contact them but they are in cartoon
and as we all know internet although
improved overnight is still patchy at
Dane Roslyn to be grateful if you could
kindly introduce yourself
thank you very much my name's Rosalind
Marsden I'm an associate fellow at
Chatham house
um I was previously the British
ambassador to Sudan and after that I was
the European Union Special
representative for Sudan and South Sudan
well thank you ever so much for joining
us today I would love if you could talk
us through how you've seen the last week
or so unfold but particularly if you
could comment on where you think that
leaves us you know what is feasible to
achieve in the current circumstances and
also and also they're much welcome your
reflection on the fact that as you know
in the foreign office the training is
always that the foreign office officials
the last out the door and they are there
till every last British national has
been removed that can be we'd welcome
your views on the fact that the British
Embassy staff had to be evacuated due to
a immediate and severe threat to their
lives
um yes well thank you um well I mean I
think as
um your previous uh panelists have
mentioned the
uh it's it's unusual really to see this
this major war taking place in the in
the national capital Khartoum um Sudan
of course has been plagued by Conflict
for many many years but they've always
taken place in the peripheries people
from the peripheries are fled to
Khartoum to seek relative safety so now
we're seeing the complete reverse of
this really large scale fighting going
on in the capital and people trying to
flee out of the capital
um
as as we know from from the reporting
from the ground I mean the the the
situation is extremely serious having
dragged now I think into the 11th day of
fighting
um the the efforts by the U.S Secretary
of State and partners to broker a
ceasefire uh to try to give another
opportunity to get foreign Nationals out
uh obviously raise some hopes that maybe
this time it would hold and as we're
seeing it's it's it's holding here and
there in Apache way
um but this is making it extremely
difficult and complex for the uh for the
foreign office to try to evacuate
British Nationals because they're being
advised to make their own way to the
assembly point to the evacuation Point
uh somewhere outside Khartoum and of
course trying to get there under their
own steam through the streets with full
of armed men uh fighting and obviously
artillery shelling going on the fighting
moving around different parts of the
city is extremely hazardous
um I mean one thing I would like to
highlight is some of the local
neighborhood resistance committees these
these young people who've been driving
the revolution they've been doing their
very best to help people in their
neighborhoods including the foreign
Nationals by sharing information about
safe well about Escape Routes
um about roadblocks where they are and
and how the fighting is moving around so
they've also been being extremely
helpful
um uh in this process but I mean what
we're also hearing from the Sudanese
side is that many Sudanese are
absolutely terrified that that once
foreign International efforts to get
their Nationals out have come to an end
then the real fighting will resume and
of course they will be they will be the
victims now on in terms of the
evacuation of diplomats that's taken
place before getting out the civilians I
mean I think
what we understand is that the diplomats
um like everybody else were basically
locked down in their houses
um in a very dangerous situation so they
were with also obviously patchy
Communications they were not really able
to fulfill their job they weren't able
to get out and meet anyone they were
also simply Sheltering in place so I
think there was a feeling that if they
were to contribute to helping the rest
of the British Community they could
probably do so better if they were out
of the country and of course the it was
also necessary for the embassy to to try
to establish how many Nationals are in
are in the Khartoum and where they are
it seems that these days the embassy
doesn't otherwise automatically register
uh all the British Nationals so that
that has taken some time
um but
um it's good to see that now it seems
from today there's there's been a
serious effort to try and start
evacuating people we saw the UN managed
to get hundreds people out by Overland
in a big Convoy to Port Sudan but that
was a major major undertaking I think it
took 24 hours to get this huge Convoy to
Portside down but they did get there
safely and I think that was UN
International staff and a number of the
international NGA workers
and class what is your assessment so the
British government has said that they
could not or did not assess it to be
safe enough to evacuate without a
ceasefire in place now many of us had
very little confidence that ceasefire
would be put in place and did the last
one held for only three hours what is
your view of the position the British
government took of waiting until there
was a ceasefire to be able to evacuate
well I
changed the the foreign office I think
has slightly changed its advice in the
last 24 hours or so to say that it
recognizes that some British Nationals
will be using their own judgment and
getting out under their own steam when
it became apparent to everyone that this
succession of ceasefires that have been
brokered by the International Community
have not been anything but but very very
partially successful so people are just
getting desperate and leaving clearly
um from the government's point of view
if they were to supervise an evacuation
process they were trying to sort of
hoping that there would be a moment when
when a humanitarian ceasefire could be
put in place and safe evacuation
corridors could be established that
would minimize the risk to attempting
this operation
um but as we've seen even with the
latest exercise
um it's it's it still leaves a very
dangerous situation but I think there's
a feeling now with people just running
out of food and water and the fighting
continuing
um that people will have to weigh up the
risk at least make an effort to give our
people an opportunity to get out and get
to and get to an Airfield whether from
which they could be evacuated and one of
the challenges obviously the British
national having to make their own way to
the airport the airstrip as you
mentioned which is incredibly dangerous
because there are no diplomatic staff
left on the ground do you think if we
were to find out the next few days weeks
that the majority of British Nationals
have taken it upon themselves to
evacuate themselves rather than using
and waiting for British evacuation would
you see that as a failure of the British
state
um I I think it's it's it's a very
difficult judgment
um clearly you know it's much easier to
evacuate 30 diplomats
um who whose whereabouts you know and to
get them out than to try to tackle the
evacuation of we understand four
thousand National British Nationals
including dual Nationals
um two thousand of which have now
registered with the embassy but the
foreign office saying that they would be
interested in being evacuated I think
trying to take on that kind of an
evacuation operation on that scale given
the intensity of the fighting that was
going on was going to be incredibly
difficult so I can understand why the
government was putting its main effort
into trying to broker a ceasefire or at
least if not it completes ceasefire some
current evacuation corridors that could
be used because that would obviously
been the safest option but despite
persistent efforts although there has
been some temporary Lull in the fighting
as we've seen which enabled some other
countries to get a number of them
Nationals out it hasn't so far resulted
in a sufficient ceasefire to be able to
I'm sure to do what the government would
like to have done in providing a safer
environment for this this exercise
and of course there was also the issue I
think that's been raised of
communication I think some British
Nationals obviously saying they've now
heard there's an evacuation operation
starting but they're all worried about
you know will they actually will they
miss a communication how they're going
to hear what's going on and I think just
a for
eign
but also the travel advice has changed
uh which is now that British Nationals
should make their own way to the
airstrip no local waiting
um I presume uh based on your comments
there that you would agree that that is
likely because of the concerns about
inability to communicate because of poor
telecoms infrastructure
um well yes I mean because we know that
the internet is down so frequently
people you know may be worried that if
they sit in their houses waiting to get
an email from the from the foreign
office that you know then it may not
come through so um I think that may be
the reason for the change of dice
and final question for me for attend
Royston the U.S has adopted the position
that they will not be evacuating their
their Nationals under any circumstances
from Sudan uh can I ask your assessment
of that and whether you feel that would
have shaped the British government's
response in the early days when they too
were not confirming that they would
evacuate British Nationals
uh well the the the Americans are saying
that they've got something like 16
000 uh Nationals including dual
Nationals in Sudan which is obviously
far more than the UK seems to have but
nevertheless the UK probably has got the
second largest number of Nationals
amongst all the all the European
countries
um so I don't know
how how uh that uh fact influenced the
British government's decision clearly
the US and the UK work very closely
together in the initial decision to
evacuate their diplomats
um and perhaps to sort of do that first
and then see what could be done
um in the very dangerous situation to
help everyone else
Royston and I mean it's a difficult
question to ask you I suppose we've been
that you're not on the ground now but do
you think that's a long-term ceasefire
is possible and what should the UK and
its Partners do to try and help to bring
that about
um well I think the most well there are
several things I think we we can do
which is first of all is to is to
continue to work very hard to try and
build up a coordinated International
response
um a coordinators of International
Coalition to put pressure on these
generals
um perhaps making clear to them that
they will be held personally accountable
if they don't abide by the the
commitments they've made
um we need also to work very closely
with regional countries who have
leverage on one side or the other to
exert that leverage and importantly not
to provide any military or financial
support to either side
um
also when it comes to you know to
actually whether the Seas first of all
can we get a ceasefire that's that is
going to be more sustainable than what
we've seen so far I think there does
need to be I think the Diplomatic
efforts do need to be intensified I mean
we've seen that there has been a a
limited degree of success in get that
enabled
um diplomats to be evacuated in some
foreign Nationals over the weekend so
the Hope was that that could be built
upon
um but I think
I mean the UK should be in a good
position to exert its diplomatic
pressure on uh International Regional
partners because the UK has been working
very closely obviously with the United
States but also that with you with the
US and Norway and the so-called Troika
it's been working in recent months with
the Saudis and the emiratis and the
so-called quad all of which has been to
support the political process uh to try
to move to democratic transition
um so I think putting continuing to work
with with those countries with other
Regional countries like South Sudan
Kenya and Djibouti which are being
mandated by the regional organization
egad to try to broker a ceasefire a lot
needs to be done to keep all these
efforts together and coherent so that
everyone's giving the same message to
the two generals and we don't start
having the whole the whole process
fragmenting but we're now seeing a
number of countries sort of volunteering
to mediate we've seen turkey mention
Israel Algeria and so on I mean I think
it's really important to try to keep
this effort coherent
I was going to ask you about mediation
actually that was my next question but
um Martin mentioned that there was no
obvious signs of any Chinese involvement
but perhaps from a mediation point of
view
um I suppose we mind who the people
mediating are as long as they get to a
position that we would want to see which
is a ceasefire do you think that they
would be involved in any of those
mediation conversations
um well we haven't seen that sort of
involvement by the Chinese so far of
course during the Bashir era they had a
very close strategic partnership with
the Bashir government particularly
during the years when when um the sort
of oil boom years in the first decade of
this this Century
um but in Chinese interest in Sudan sort
of declined quite a bit after South
Sudan's Independence in 2011 when most
of the oil was was remained in the South
um so China's role in recent years has
been more low-key and they've take
Chinese companies have taken some
interest in in Sudan's gold reserves
um but so far we haven't sort of seen
them really
looking as if they're going to volunteer
to develop mediation role
thank you thank you chair um thank you
thank you for your evidence so far um
given your experience do you think there
were opportunities missed by the UK or
its Partners in uh to try and stop this
conflict developing into violence
um well
well it's the answer to that question
one point I wanted to make which wasn't
didn't really really out I think from
your first two
um uh panelists was that I think this
what we're seeing at the moment is is of
course a power struggle between two
generals and uh but it's also
um an attempt to derail Sudan's
democratic transition and and to return
and to return Sudan to the control of
the former regime I mean this is a point
which is being emphasized extremely
strongly by Sudan's pro-democracy
civilian and political leaders and
they've been they've been sort of
warning the International Community and
indeed the fellow Sudanese for quite
some time uh that the elements of the
old regime were trying to widen the rift
between the Army and the rapid support
Force
um
because they wanted to destabilize the
transition process
um and I think um that therefore that
point has to be properly understood by
International uh governments including
the British government in order to sort
of decide
to understand the situation properly
there was a very important statement put
out about three days ago signed by
Sudan's main pro-democratic political
parties many national figures and
intellectuals sort of basically
announcing a United civilian front to
resist the return of the former regime
and I think this statement does need to
be taken seriously we've we've also seen
during during Ramadan we saw some of the
um the members of the former National
Congress party the ruling party under
beshear
um calling for the release of President
Bashir from prison
um sort of mobilizing their both their
members but also the the so-called um
islamist Shadow battalions so um I mean
this is this this issue it's not just a
propaganda issue from hermiti although
of course he's using it but this is
certainly a strongly held view
um by
um the pro-democracy move movement so on
the one hand I think the British British
government and its Partners perhaps
should have taken that those warnings
more seriously
um they the UK was working extremely
actively with its Partners to support
the political process based on the
framework agreement at the 5th of
December
um which would have and that this was in
its final stages to move towards
appointing a civilian prime minister
um a civilian cabinet and a civilian
head of state and there were high hopes
that although the agreement was far from
perfect it was certainly a big positive
move in the right direction but of
course as always with this kind of
political process it's the last stages
that are the most dangerous where the
spoilers are likely to step out their
efforts I think again there were
warnings that this might be the case I
myself wrote an article for Chatham
House towards the end of March sort of
highlighting the fact that high level
International intervention was required
at that critical moment to obviously to
increase the pressure particularly on
the two military leaders who were
arguing over security to reform and the
the issue of how long it should take to
integrate the rapid support Force into
the army we did see on the American side
we saw Molly fee who's you know the
assistant Secretary of State for Africa
picked up the phone and spoke to himity
to Bohan and to one of the civilian
political leaders I didn't know whether
any British ministers picked up the
phone as well but it was at that crucial
window I think where
um it was really a case of high-level
attention should have been focused on
the the final stage of the political
process and of course now the the war
has broken out there's very high level
attention from from the British
government here and from other
governments but in a way
it's necessary sometimes when you don't
have a war but you're at a crucial stage
of a political process and I think
perhaps that's where more might have
been done
and can I ask as given the UK government
was the U.N security Council pen holder
would you specifically expected them to
have done more during that period
um well I think the UK managed in the
very early stage of the war to get us a
press statement quickly out of the U.N
security Council
um obviously condemning the fighting
calling for an immediate ceasefire which
given the current climate in the
security Council with the Russians I
think was quite an achievement they
managed to get the Russians and the
Chinese to sign up to this so I think
they did actually use the position as
pen holder to move quickly to achieve
that
Chris
just wonder what how you think other
Regional
battles that are going on and and our um
different countries in the region
seeking
um more Authority more power how that is
playing out within
um Sudan yes thank you well I think the
number of countries Regional countries
obviously that have interest in Sudan I
think the perhaps the one I would
highlight is Egypt
um which has uh obviously a very strong
historical links with Sudan going back
centuries but it was also Sudan was a
part of the anglo-egyptian condominium
in the first half of you know the last
century
um they regard Sudan the Egyptians
regarded down very much as a national
security issue and policy on Sudan is
made by the Egyptian intelligence
service rather than a foreign Ministry
um that Egypt has been a very strong
backer of
um the Sudanese Army and president uh
sorry General Bohan
um the there are very close links
between the two armies many the many the
Sydney's army officers go and train in
the Egyptian military academies
um there's for the since March 2021
there's been a military cooperation
agreement between the Sudanese Army and
the Egyptian Army and they've been
conducting military military and and air
and Naval drills
um
there's also a strong interest on the
Egyptian side in trying to keep Sudan as
an ally in its negotiations with
Ethiopia over the grand Renaissance Dam
which for the Egyptians are seen as a
sort of existential issue from their
point of view and it would seem that the
government in Egypt
um has would certainly have a strong
preference to see a military officer
like Bohan in control in Sudan
um rather than well certainly rather
than a militia leader like hamiti on and
rather than a civilian democratic
government which might not be so easy to
to influence
um it's also been clear that the
Egyptians have have been intervening in
Sudanese political Affairs they invited
in earlier this year a number of
Sudanese political actors to go to Cairo
um to sort of help to form a broader
political grouping which many Sudanese
and some International actor saw as an
attempt to create a rather parallel
political process to the one that the
United Nations the Au and egat were
already
facilitating with support from from the
Western governments so the the Egyptians
were a major player but it means they do
have leverage of course on uh
particularly on General Bohan and the
Army and therefore for the UK it's very
important to being being very close
touch with the Egyptians to try to
encourage them to work together with the
rest of the the International Community
the United Arab Emirates are also worth
mentioning because
they um have they've had closed ties
with with General committee uh
particularly because of the Yemen War
hermit he put a big military contingent
into the Yemen war on this on the side
of the Saudi Lake Coalition the Army
also puts has put soldiers in but not
not so many
um the emiratis also have an interest in
trying to control to get control of a
commercial port on the Red Sea
um they have a big interest in Sudan
from the point of view of food security
they had just announced a six billion
dollar investment in a in fact in a new
port on the Red Sea that would be linked
to a massive agricultural project
um but I don't think the UAE uh
completely on one side they've they've
got lit quite good links also with with
General Bohan and the Army as well so
they've got links with both sides and
then of course there's Saudi Arabia
which I think is if anything probably
more neutral between the two and it's
been with Saudi Arabia and the United
Arab Emirates that the UK has been
working together with the Americans to
try and leverage their influence on on
the military leaders
through that huge financial power to try
to prevent this escalation that has so
sadly gone ahead
any Russian meddling
uh well the Russians as as has been
mentioned already have obviously been
trying to expand their footprint in this
part of Africa and Sudan has been one of
their target countries their interests
are primarily trying to secure a Russian
naval base on the Red Sea Coast which
they uh had in 2017 negotiated with
President Bashir before he was
overthrown and they're still pushing to
try to get this agreement to be
implemented but
[Music]
is very well aware of regional
resistance to that coming from Egypt and
not some other countries
um they've been working through the
Wagner group closely with the humidity
and the rapid support Force providing we
understand some training and
sort of social media advice
um also working closely in exploiting
some of the gold mining operations
um and in the UN Security Council the
Russians have tended to always really
tend to protect the interests of the
military jumped up so to speak
especially after the October 2021 coup
visits the civilians
um and they've they've always tended to
oppose International intervention
um
the Russians have also been a major
supplier of military hardware to the
Sudanese Army and lavrov was in Khartoum
just a couple of months ago on that
occasion he met both Bohan and himiti so
the Russians have got links to both
sides
um which may be one of the reasons why
they were willing in the security
Council to at least work with everyone
else to call for a ceasefire
um rather than trying to stop the
fighting
Rosalind if the instability continues in
Sudan what impact do you think that will
have in terms of a risk greater risk of
terrorist Recruitment and what is the
impact of that on UK's security and
foreign policy interests
uh well if the war continues and and
sort of it spreads into a protracted
Civil War
um drawing in domestic and and probably
then Regional actors
um obviously there is a risk that you
will have breakdown of Law and Order
ungoverned space in which there could be
potential scope for terrorist groups to
move in
um this has also always been one of the
big big concerns
um so I think there is a I mean there's
obviously the concern that it could lead
to a much greater increase in so to
speak ex migration but I think terrorism
as well is another another issue
um
uh we you know in the past in the when
we in the early days of the Bashir
regime in the 1990s of course the
national Islamic front and uh Hassan
al-turabi actively invited uh terrorism
all over the world Osama Bin Laden and
many others to Khartoum so I mean I
think the issue is do we see elements of
that regime if they were to come back uh
into the you know into greater power
than they've had for the last four years
will that lead to to the risk of of sort
of terrorist groups being allowed to
come in
and we're going to wrap up that I'm
afraid uh thank you ever so much Dane
Rosland as I said uh sadly we had to cut
every session down to half now but I'm
very pleased we were able to have that
half hour with you uh please do feel
free to keep the committee update as
things go on I'm sure you will have left
part of your heart in sudama you'll be
there and see how it goes forward
thank you so much also spend briefly in
public just to allow us to change over
ding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently
[Applause]
order order welcome back to this session
of the Foreign Affairs committee where
we are now joined by the African
Minister Andrew Mitchell uh Minister can
I thank you first of all I know many
ministers would probably have said that
they were too busy in the crisis center
to come at this time to speak to us so I
am grateful to you for your time
um I'd be very grateful if you could
start with an update on the evacuation
for us and how many British Nationals we
believe at this time we've managed to
get out
thank you very much chair and um I thank
you all so very much for agreeing that
this will just be a very quick session
and I hope if the committee wants to uh
invite me back uh in slow time
um that I might get an invitation
um so I I apologize to the committee
that this is only a sort of 20-minute
slot
um the position is that the UK is
supporting the departure of British
Nationals from Sudan we are asking
British Nationals to travel to Woody
Saida field before uh eight o'clock
cartoon time today to be processed for
supported departure seats will be
allocated on a priority basis starting
with family groups with children and or
the elderly or individuals with
documented medical conditions people
should continue to ensure that they have
logged locations and contact detail
details with the foreign office we are
continuing to work up other options to
assist British Nationals wanting to
leave Sudan including at other points of
exit travel within Sudan is conducted at
British Nationals own risks and plans
may change depending on the security
situation that is an update chair on
where we stand thank you and do you
still believe to be the right assessment
not to have evacuate at an earlier point
before the ceasefire was in place yes I
mean we have been in crisis mode now for
more than a week we have at all times
been exploring every possible option for
all British Nationals and of course for
our own Embassy staff to whom we owe a
specific duty of of care as their
employer and at all times we've been
working 24 7 you will remember from your
own knowledge of the foreign office the
way the crisis center operates there's a
crisis center now with 200 people
government
joined across government at the hip the
Prime Minister has just made visit to
thank our staff in the crisis center but
they've been working flat out day and
night to look after and contact British
Nationals and also to make sure that we
look at all conceivable options and
every option we try to advance as
quickly as we can can I asked did the
U.S is a very early decision they would
not evacuate any of their Nationals
impact on our decision making
no although I have to say that we talk
very closely to our long-established
partners about those options so I'm sure
there was some cross fertilization of
thinking but we made the decision to
evacuate the British mission in cartoon
because of the extreme danger that our
diplomats are in as I told the house
yesterday the the uh there were we were
really positioned between the two sides
it was extremely dangerous and we made
the decision that we should evacuate
them when we did
have an assessment of how many British
Nationals have taken it
on their own back to try and get
themselves a cartoon because they didn't
believe an evacuation was coming
no we have we have no assessment of that
and of course you know there will be
British Nationals who know the local
area and the territory extremely well
um and they may have disregarded the
advice of the foreign office or indeed
have accepted the advice yesterday which
changed from uh it's you should stay
indoors in safety because it is simply
too dangerous out on the streets of of
uh khartoumas all as all subsequent
events have suggested
um uh so that advice yesterday changed
if you do decide that you are going to
move you do so very much at your own
risk but I accept there will be there
will have been people who know the area
very well who will have made that
calculation thank you Chris I'm gonna
ask you a point that was made by Martin
Platt earlier which was that um some
British Nationals
passports might be in the British
Embassy safe
um what what are you going to do about
people who turn up unable to be
documented
well they should have already been the
subject of a call from the foreign
office and no doubt will have explained
that position
ultimately it will be for the officials
who are now on the ground there from the
home office and the foreign office uh uh
running the facility which is processing
people to make that decision on the
ground but but you know we have we have
given an order of priority
um and that order will will
um pertain so so one would hope that the
foreign office would already have been
aware of these circumstances and that
the rdt would take a reasonable view one
would hope
was quite a dangerous sort of assumption
well it's the nature of these things
um and um I I think that you know we've
got this clear order in which we're
going to seek to evacuate people there's
a 72-hour ceasefire so far it has held
and we must uh hope and pray that it
continues to do so
we've heard different views as to
whether it's holding and whether it's
holding very strong very convincingly or
not your view is that it's holding
I I have I have no recent updates to
suggest that it isn't
um as you will know the previous uh a
large number of ceasefires didn't hold
at all this one has certainly held since
it started at midnight uh so far
and it's possible that an event such as
this will lead to significant amount of
migration
both to other neighboring countries and
potentially much further on people might
end up coming across in boats
might end up Crossing into Europe On A
Boat it might end up coming through to
the UK on a boat would they then be
deported to Rwanda
well that is at least at the moment a
hypothetical question if you if you
turned up at the airstrip in uh Khartoum
uh seeking to be an asylum Seeker you
would not be eligible because you cannot
be an asylum Seeker from your own
country so
um I think that is the first and most
significant point to make and I imagine
the Border force would say that they've
got an order of priority uh that they
are allowed to accept which was the
order laid down by the government and
that that would mean that they wouldn't
be eligible anyway but but you can't be
an asylum Seeker from your own country
I can't just ask Minister apologies I
haven't seen it publicly confirmed that
we deployed rdt teams but it sounded
there like we had yes they have they've
they've arrived um in the
um the airstrip and they arrived early
this morning and they are in action
there
thank you for your time today and all
you're doing
um I've got a couple of constituents who
are stuck in uh start at the moment or
just received uh information that they
think it's too risky and because of your
shortage to make it to the airstrip
um is there any other revenue for them
to get there or you know get to the port
of Sudan uh for alternative means no all
those uh and some have already been
evacuated I would have left
um all those who have come have come
under their own steam uh We've adopted
actually the same procedure that the
Germans adopted uh successfully
yesterday
um and
um uh they they came under their own
Steam and we're asking people to do the
same
yeah uh thanks
Abdullah has told an NHS cardiologists
have told the times that he was trying
to get in touch with the foreign office
and others and being greeted by radio
silence
the British staff of the cartoon
American school told that they were
directed to a foreign office website
filled in the forms they say that they
have done everything the British
government asked me to do phoned up got
my name on the consulate list filled in
their forms but not once did I get a
personalized email the only thing you
get is a link to the website that is
travel advice about Saddam Alison
letting in a dual British Finnish
National hit by a bullet in the foot
says that she has been in constant touch
through phone and WhatsApp with the
Finnish Embassy that's been ignored by
UK officials many of these people turned
to the French in order to escape the
country
do you think that the French are doing a
better job at evacuating their citizens
than the UK
um no I don't I think everyone is going
about this in their own way we have much
larger numbers of citizens to take out I
I mean I have enormous sympathy with the
difficulties that those uh British
citizens whom you've just read out are
facing but uh if they contact the
foreign-offs the the travel advice is
extremely uh important because it does
change and it's changed it changed
yesterday and it's changed again today
so so keeping in touch with the the
travel advice is is not an insignificant
matter but we have tried that anyone who
has registered with the foreign office
has to uh should receive and has
received a message at least once a day
the problem is that the atmospherics uh
in Khartoum hinder that sort of
communication yesterday there was only
two percent internet and that does make
communicating extremely uh difficult
um but in principle that has been what
we have tried to achieve and I spent
some several time
on recent days in the crisis center and
I've seen what our staff are doing so
well both in in speaking to and
comforting those who are in a state of
great anxiety and I completely
understand that
so you know the system is working but it
is spasmodic as as you described
presumably because we have more
Nationals to evacuate we are surging in
more um evacuation capacity than other
countries like France do you think that
by the end of tomorrow we'll evacuated
more of our citizens than say the French
have
well I think I'm not really going to get
into numbers because I I would could not
do so with confidence but what I I can
say is that we are as we have been for
the last week extremely focused on every
single conceivable way of extracting our
citizens uh every single type of help
that we can give them we are exploring
other options as well at the moment but
for the moment we are evacuating people
from the airstrip north of uh Khartoum
and that operation uh so far is going
well we can't give any assurances of
that what documents are being accepted
by means of identity at the airport well
for most of the people who are coming up
there ideally they have already been
pre-cleared because they've told us
about their documents and we've been
able therefore to tell them to come and
when they come they will be waved
through by the officials who are there
but otherwise we are expecting them to
have a British passport and and so so
far I'm not aware of any problems in
that process if families come with
dependency who are not British Nationals
or British citizens are they being
accepted onto the outbound flights well
there's a there's a categorization of
um different groupings they are the
families with children uh Elder folk
people with medical conditions and
there's there's a sort of prioritization
order in that respect if you arrive at
the airport with children under the age
of 18 who are who do not have documents
so long as the Border Force officers who
are there are content that you are a
family unit then you will get on the
plane how are they making that judgment
how will they how are they making that
judgment well they they just have to
satisfy themselves that the that the if
the travel documents are not complete
that the children are who they're till
they are and there hasn't been an issue
with that and if someone themselves
wants to claim Asylum because their life
is in Jeopardy in Sudan
at what stage in this evacuation process
should they make that claim for Asylum
um as Mr burn will know you can't make
an application from from Sudan if you're
a Sudanese citizen
um so the the international regulations
that govern these things would not uh
would not work for you if they make that
claim for Asylum when they land in the
UK what will happen to their claim but
it will be you know it's coming by some
other means at the moment it would be it
would be depends how they arrive but it
would it would be assessed in the normal
way if they're a Sudanese citizen who
has come onto a flight for example with
a British parent for example
um and they land in this country and
they want to claim Asylum will that
Asylum claim be processed in in a normal
way well it's very difficult to conceive
how a Sudanese citizen today would
arrive by plane from Sudan in the UK
with a British parent
well they won't get on the flight unless
we are satisfied about their documents
there may be some who do have a
legitimate claim to Asylum who are left
on the tarmac in Sudan well I think I
think we spent we're getting round in
circles they they they do not have
eligibility to claim Asylum policy that
they do not have eligibility to claim
Asylum uh when they uh if if they were
to come and seek uh to be evacuated from
uh by the British evacuation Mission
um at the moment I think the
clarification point is now where we've
only got seven minutes left if somebody
comes as a dependent when they arrive in
the UK what is their Asylum status
because they are not seeking Asylum
necessary they have come as a direct
dependent or would they be required to
apply for Asylum to have to stay here in
the long term well if I if I'm not an
expert on this area of law but if I have
understood your question correctly chair
um if they can get on the flight out of
uh north of the airstrip north of
Khartoum on the basis that they get on
that flight they will be able to be
transplant in Cyprus and come
um very briefly um to your point about
prioritization though there will be some
British Nationals who'll be unable to
get to the airstrip because they do not
have fuel because they are so unwell
from having not had enough food and
drink or because of medical age that
they haven't been able to access we do
not have diplomats on the ground to go
and get them in a convoy is the RTD got
permission to go and extract British
Nationals no the RTD is based at the uh
airstrip
um and it is from there that they will
operate but I I'm not aware of of all
the people who've registered I'm not
aware of anyone who falls into that
category
minister of the UK is of course uh the
pen holder and the security Council at
the un uh on Sudan what are the next
steps that the government are planning
uh at the un uh on uh this issue well
you put your finger on the critical
point which is that what is urgently
required is a ceasefire for the
combatants to lay down their arms and
return to barracks and for the political
process which was moving forward
significantly uh before the second week
of April for that to reassert itself and
Britain will do everything it can
through holding the pen at the United
Nations we are in a special position and
we have already exercised that
application since this crisis has
started
um but we will do everything we can
together with our colleagues at the
United Nations together with our friends
and colleagues in Europe together with
the regional Paz the foreign secretary
has been on the phone
to our colleagues in the region uh
ceaselessly since this crisis started to
try and move people towards the
possibility and then the actuality of a
of a ceasefire but that is the critical
uh thing that is required there is going
to be a humanitarian catastrophe there
with the position at the moment in terms
of food and the humanitarian relief most
of the humanitarian workers have uh are
leaving and they will not be able to
come back until there is a ceasefire and
there is some degree of safety on the
ground five of them have already been
murdered
Kristen
um
I understand why you evacuated
foreign office staff of no reason to
doubt your intelligence that they were
their lives were
in danger
I wonder though which is what I thought
on the weekend about the Optics of
senior cabinet tweeting
1200 military involved in taking our
people out while British citizens were
left in cartoon wondering what was going
to happen to them so I'm pleased that we
now have moved on and things are
gathering Pace but do you think that's a
sensible way to promote that
but I think that you have to accept that
the decision was made I mean the Prime
Minister chaired a cobra uh last
Saturday morning
um at 3 15 in the morning and I think
that gives a feeling of the urgency and
the tense critical complexity of the
situation uh we then decided that the
people for whom we had a very specific
responsibility and I emphasize that the
government feels a responsibility for
all British citizens in Sudan but the
people who were our own employees the
diplomats their dependents people who
were in the in the uh Britain British
Home British houses and the residents
and the embassy
um were in sufficient Jeopardy for us to
know that military operations should be
launched and no government puts lightly
the men and women of our military into
Harm's Way and I pay great tribute to
their bravery so I think the the Tweet
to which you are referring
reflects the pride and admiration of the
defense secretary in the remarkable work
that the British Armed Forces conducted
getting all our
Embassy staff out while one who is now
out and in Djibouti getting them all out
successfully and also getting all the
troops who were involved in the
operation safely back to Cyprus as well
Chris
we've heard
this afternoon in our evidence two
different versions uh two different
answers to the question should we have
known that this was a possibility
um uh one going well it would have been
very difficult but others saying well
actually the alarm Bell should have been
ringing because we knew that this was
getting into very tense moment in the
process towards democracy and lots of
people didn't want to go back to
democracy and I just wonder do you think
um where do you fall on those on that
spectrum and and if there could have
been any alarm bells ringing wouldn't it
have been a good idea to have
garnered information about how many
British Nationals there were in Sudan
rather earlier so that we might have
been able to
we would have been ready to have put
something in place well well on the
second Point
um we only know if people tell us and
quite often British Nationals don't tell
the embassy and the um so the emcee has
to make a judgment and uh you know the
judgments we have made in terms of
British Nationals and those with dual
passports are uh are in in the public
domain on the basis of the first
question that Sir Christopher asked me
which is should we have known I think
that is it I think that is very
difficult I mean I don't my answer is no
uh and obviously we've been work done in
the foreign office very good ambassador
there
um and uh that work monitors and works
very closely with the different people
involved in particular of course with
civil society and the and the
politicians rather than the military but
this is not an ideological battle this
is a battle between two generals uh for
power
uh there's no ideology involved in this
is raw power
um being fought over
um and one might have hoped that that
would uh never happen given the
appalling humanitarian uh Jeopardy it
has placed so many people in what we
heard earlier was quite a lot of
Engagement from other countries outside
wanting to meddle wanting to
um including possibly the Baldwin group
Russia Libya
um Egypt all of these things were
available for us to know and I
a
there's a bit of my mind that's just
going well we take our eye off the ball
when when we know that we have quite a
lot of British citizens
in Sudan
um I don't think so we were watching
very carefully over the peace process it
did appear to be making progress one has
to remember that throughout most of the
time uh that uh after the
um British protectorate in Sudan I think
it was uh Madam chair uh throughout most
of that time there's been a military
government in Sudan so so the progress
that we were working towards where there
might be a civilian government with huge
hopes and of an enormous bravery of the
people who were standing up for
democracy and the political uh the
political leaders in Sudan we were very
close to them we knew what was going on
and we hoped that that progress would
continue to be made in respect of those
negotiations but as I say you know I
think that we would not have expected
that these two generals would have
slugged it out in this way on a totally
non-ideological issue let alone
deployed heavy weapons and built up
areas I just urge you to read the
evidence that we've had earlier
afterwards I think it might be quite
revealing for you I shall I always look
at the evidence that it was published by
the minister I'm aware that you need to
leave us but we will be taking up on
your offer to come back to us again and
I hope not the near to your future
um I would also just like to put on
record that the Hearts and Thoughts of
this entire committee go out the people
of Sudan and also to all the British
Nationals who have caught up and have
lived through an unbearably scary few
days and also to put on record our
thanks the staff at the foreign office
the mod the armed forces and the Border
force and now those rdts on the ground
we all hope that ceasefire holds but
also I think we would all urge to try
and get as many British Air Nationals
out as we can as possible and just to
reiterate those who may be joining us
late the message is that any British
national should travel immediately to
the airstrip so that they can be
evacuated thank you ever so much
Minister order order